[Musique]
il y avait un truc qui ce qui c'est qui
se superposent et dans le livre l'une
qui concerne le laboratoire de luan les
pilotes qui porte sur l'intelligence
artificielle est quelque chose qui a été
fait par le google était diffusée par le
financial times et qui était tout de
suite retirée des médias à la demande de
google
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y à un certain nombre de blockhaus
qui ont été construits par les allemands
à la 2eme durant la seconde guerre
mondiale et il y en a un qui est énorme
qui fait le plus de casse mais 500 m²
qui est une véritable aguerris table
immeuble souterrain et une partie de
l'intérêt du ce se passe dans cet
immeuble où a été installé une salle de
contrôle du fameux ordinateur
gérald artérielle l'intelligence
artificielle de quelque chose que l'on
peut découvrir dans le vivant c'est un
beau roman d'aventuré il à dire que
effectivement si le sujet est triste un
petit peu le comité c'est quelque chose
qui est triste
bon là on n'est pas dans un seul à
nantes et on est en train de se balader
dans le monde à découvrir des gens